wir wissen ja union berlin und hertha
bsc streben auch an mit 5000 zuschauern
zu spielen das lässt die
senatsverwaltung hierzu wir wissen dass
eintracht frankfurt in gesprächen ist
mit dem gesundheitsamt und sich bis zu
20.000 auch alles vorstellen kann ist
dass der eine dominostein der jetzt in
leipzig um gefallen ist und der dazu
führen wird dass wir möglicherweise
schon beim bundesliga start am
wochenende 18 bis 20 september noch mehr
stadien mit zuschauern erleben werden
ich kann mir das durchaus vorstellen
weil natürlich werden jetzt die fragen
laut warum sachsen was ja ganz klar
anteilen hängt an dieser niedrigen
incidents von fällen da kann ja jetzt
jedes bundesland was ebenfalls niedrige
fälle seien
na ja gut wenn die das machen warum
machen wir das nicht diese fragen werden
laut wenn wir wissen aus hamburg das der
bürgermeister dort auch eigentlich dafür
war mit fans zu starten das ist nicht
ein in sachsen exclusive modell das ist
etwas wo es in vielen ländern durchaus
sympathien vergibt bei der kanzlerin und
bei markus söder muss man klar sein gab
es überhaupt keine sympathien für aber
natürlich ist das das hintertürchen
jetzt auf und das hintertürchen kann man
ganz schnell einreißen und da werden
sehr viel sehr sehr schnell sehr viele
durchgehen und das muss man auch sagen
es gibt ja bei dieser industrie
bundesliga durchaus auch wirtschaftliche
interessen mit fans zu spielen einfach
weil es wirtschaftlich wichtig ist da
wird der druck jetzt glaube ich enorm
und ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen
dass wir am ersten bundesliga-spieltag
auch in anderen stadien schon in leipzig
hast du gesagt geht es erst am zweiten
spieltag darum weil da das erste
heimspiel stattfindet aber dass wir auch
schon am ersten spieltag fans sehen
werden in bereichen in denen es weniger
infektionen gibt und vielleicht noch ein
punkt das kommt dazu dass politisch
glaube ich auch extrem wichtig jens
spahn hat gestern in einem
bemerkenswerten auftritt wohl wieder
niedergebrüllt wurde trotzdem hat er
sich diesen auftritt gestellt gesagt mit
dem wissen von heute hätte man die
friseure nicht schließen und die
altersheime nicht so abriegeln müssen
wie man das getan hat das heißt bei
dieser bandbreite im prinzip übersetzt
sehr viel von den massnahmen damals war
sehr viel jahr zwischen diesen beiden
politik wäre mit dem wissen von heute
eigentlich nicht nötig gewesen
das kombiniert vieles was wir gemacht
haben wäre nicht nötig gewesen mit
sachsen macht es jetzt ohnehin und lässt
fans
das stadion wird aus meiner sicht das
potenzial darin erdrutsche auszulösen